hey if you don't know I am here the
wrong place
this is the wired autocomplete interview
I said it right
where did Samuel Jackson where is Samuel
Jackson from born in Washington DC but
grew up in Chattanooga Tennessee where
is Samuel Jackson right now in room in
downtown LA of the storm and outside
where is Samuel Jackson in Inglourious
Basterds Tarantino voiceover heaven
where did Samuel Jackson go to high
school Chattanooga Tennessee Riverside
High is samuel l.jackson a vegan I was
but I'm not anymore is Samuel Jackson
related to Michael Jackson nope is
samuel l.jackson in every Tarantino
movie I'm not in death Proof I'm in
wanted to kill bills one or two but not
the other one is Samuel Jackson in
Goodfellas yeah yeah give him a brains
blown out by Joe Pesci Oh spoiler alert
for those of you who haven't seen it is
little Jackson sponsored by Kangol no
did Samuel Jackson's did Samuel Jackson
leave America several times over the
past few months did Samuel Jackson sing
in Black Snake Moan
yeah to some people's children other
people's joy did send me a little
Jackson get an Oscar no-bid sent me
little Jackson go to UGA nope I actually
went to Morehouse College when I am a
UGA fan did send me a little Jackson
asked for a purple lightsaber you bet
your ass I did I asked George and he
said no I went away came back to do
reshoots and he said that's what I did
just for the hell of it said he'd made
me but he still wasn't sure he was gonna
actually keep it I ended up keeping it
fly well we'll send me a little
Jackson's first movie together for Day
starring Calvin and Lockhart don't go
looking for it
what did samuel l.jackson engrave on
lightsaber BMF on the on/off button what
scripture did samuel l.jackson quote pop
fiction if you don't know that you're
not a pulp fiction fan what happened to
samuel l.jackson in Jurassic Park I
guess I got eaten they ripped my arm off
and left
and a shed somewhere I never did
actually get to go to Hawaii to shoot
that same said I was supposed to work on
or run from the Raptors through who got
blown away by a hurricane
what movie does samuel l.jackson say yes
they deserve to die time to kill
available or no does Samuel Jackson play
guitar I learned to play guitar for
Black Snake Moan
samuel l.jackson like enemy yes I do
hint I too have a list no that was an
affectation for film samuel l.jackson
smoked cigarettes no not anymore
no samuel l.jackson have a wife yes I do
37 years how send me a little Jackson
how much it sent me well Jackson worth
more than I thought I'd ever be
how many movies has samuel l.jackson
been in I'm not really sure but things a
lot though how did send me a little
Jackson become famous that's your fault
not mine much better to be rich how did
samuel l.jackson die random samuel
l.jackson I guess references semi-load
Jackson yes you did
yes I made it Samuel Jackson on trunk
I've never been on that dude nasty let
me little Jackson bacon number there's a
bacon number is that Samuel Jackson they
yeah Samuel Jackson vs. cat would that
be that Fallon thing that I did while I
was trying to explain the raid to some
kittens Sammy little Jackson
hockey coach pretty funny skit I did
hosted in the ESPYs one year right I
hope that's been informative for you
maybe you found out something you didn't
know my life's an open and bull